hey everybody my name is Greg and today
I'm going to take you on a journey into
my head scary I know but I'm going to
share with you my process and my
decision-making and all the steps that I
go through when I make an illustration
now we're gonna take a look at a handful
of drawings I did on the iPad pro using
procreate and you're gonna be with me
the whole time now if you do want to see
more of that stuff you can check out my
Instagram there's a link in the
description below but if not just kick
back and enjoy the ride so let's start
at the beginning with with an idea and
specifically how do you come up with an
idea I came up with this when I was just
home doodling on my couch with my dog
sitting next to me and I remember you
know just kind of thinking really know
how to draw a dog maybe I'll draw a Lucy
and I'd also remembered like my wife had
just bought this really cool new jacket
it's like big and kind of mustard yellow
and almost acai cool a square shape and
I was like oh you know maybe maybe let's
do like a little family portrait here so
I started doodling the two of them just
standing there like what would they look
like if they're on a walk or something
and that's kind of where I came up with
this fundamental theme then when I
started going on into the world I would
start paying attention to people walking
their dogs and their fashion choices and
what they were wearing and I started to
generate this kind of overall theme of
year of the dog but what if it was year
of the dog walkers instead that was
enough at that point I had a theme to
work with so when I wanted to make a new
drawing I didn't have to sit there and
you know scratch my head and say oh I
could just say okay new dog walker it
made that first drawing and out that was
great that was cool and I decided you
know this was going to be my theme
moving forward so what I wanted to do is
establish a set of rules for myself to
to make it make it even easier to
produce and I find that really helps me
you know and I'm not trying to invent
things every time I sit down to do
something so my rule is really simple
one character one dog breed no
background just a solid color and it
needs to work in the square format and
that was my box at this stage had a
theme I had some rules
I had a general direction I was going so
let's talk about what happens next
you know the idea is in place I'm kind
of getting ready to draw at this point
but before I do that before I make a
single mark it's sort of like mentally
plan what I imagine the end result
looking like and this all goes on in my
head you know some thinking about okay
like who is this character and what dog
breed are they paired with where I
typically start is just google image
search I'll look up reference for what
the character is wearing you know like
what is their fashion style what's their
hair like and how are they standing what
is it what is their body language tell
us and I I go until I find something
that really kind of sparks it could be
anything really it could be other type
of like pattern that I see or a jacket
in the way it fits in the shape so an
interesting example is that this
character was actually inspired by
someone I saw in the real world so my
wife and I were out shopping in a
department store and this this lovely
woman was helping us she had this just
rad hairdo you and these giant hoop
earrings and like heard heard her like
up bun was like a perfect sphere it was
amazing it was really cool like her her
sense of style and fashion everything
was just fantastic and I used some of
that to draw this character and pull it
from it once I have a good idea for the
character what they're wearing and
everything and they're kind of looking
like hey you know how you standing what
are you doing I start to think okay now
what dog would pair well with them what
kind of story are they going to tell
when they're together I try to look for
any kind of story in there sometimes
I'll see it right away you know be like
oh obviously you know you're going to
have a pitbull obviously you're gonna
have two chihuahuas and it just works so
well
other times I go back to trusty Google
Image Search and I have a bookmark
actually have like just different dog
breeds I can just scroll through and
find really interesting shapes and their
faces and you know try to look for stuff
that I that speaks to the character that
I that I'm thinking about drawing I'm
like yeah you know what you look like
you would be with that person and that
makes a lot of sense okay so now you
know how I think what I do
process to approaching illustration I
hope that you guys can use some of this
stuff and to do a quick recap first of
all let's see you want to find a theme
so you don't just have to invent
something new every time you know do
like a week theme or a month theme with
like a 30 day challenge something just
to kind of keep you on track and then
set up some rules to yourself to follow
so you don't you know over blow some
project keep it simple give yourself a
box to work with them it'll really
really help and then lastly just have a
general direction that you want ahead
you know and I think once you have a
theme and some rules figured out that'll
really come to light and when in doubt
pull reference go out explore the world
meet people talk to people you know
don't wait to be inspired go and seek
out inspiration or just you know find
something and copy it and learn do
something okay so I hope this stuff
helps you guys and if you want to see
more videos like this let me know in the
comments below I would love to share
more of this stuff
thanks for your time see you next time
you